today I'd like to talk to you about a
new method for solving circuits last
time we reviewed using KVL KCl and Ohm's
law in order to solve circuits in the
general sense this produced a lot of
equations and in particular a lot of
redundant equations there are a lot of
dependent equations that we don't
necessarily need for solving her circuit
today I'm going to review the node
voltage component current method which
is very similar to node analysis so if
you hear one versus the other know that
you're talking about approximately the
same thing and I'll review the
difference in a second once we know how
to use at the NBCC method for solving
circuits we can express our the
relationships between components in our
circuit more concisely and more
effectively and possibly solve our
equations faster which is relevant when
we're you know working on a midterm or
in the general sense just trying to save
time let's take a look at MVCC as I said
before nvcc stands for node voltage
component current and what that means is
if you have a very simple circuit let's
say just a voltage source and a couple
resistors
previously with KBL we were interested
in the voltage drop around a loop being
equivalent to zero in this case we're
actually going to look at the voltage
drop assist or the voltages associated
with particular nodes to do that we're
going to label our nodes which are
anywhere our components connect we're
also going to go after the component
current when we're doing KCl we
typically look at the flow in and out of
a particular node at this point we're
going to look at the flow through a
given component so we're also going to
label all of the currents associated
with our circuit but when we approach
nvcc method we're going to think about
the currents flowing through a
particular component as opposed to in
and out of a particular node it's sort
of the NBCC is sort of the opposite of
KVL and KCl in that sense even though
you're still going to end up using the
same relationships
so at this point I've labeled the
currents going through I've labeled one
individual current for every component
in my circuit the next step would be to
identify what I'm going to call ground
or in particular one of my nodes I'm
going to sign the ground or relative
voltage zero at that point I'm going to
write out the relationships between the
voltage drop across particular
components the current flowing through
that particular component and whatever
relationship the component requires the
voltage and the current to have to one
another that's a rule rend review of
MVCC method note analysis is very
similar the main difference between node
analysis and MVCC method is when your
component is a voltage source and there
are multiple currents flowing into that
voltage source you can treat this as a
single voltage you can treat this as a
single voltage node where this voltage
node has value zero and actually write
your KCl equations as though this point
were collapsed so current flowing in and
current flowing out or vice-versa have
to sum to zero that's the major
difference let's look at an example
you can find this example repeat it in
six point four point three of the
readings and I'm going to walk through
these directions so the first thing I'm
going to do is label my notes and my
currents people interchangeably use e or
n it doesn't really matter I guess N in
particular could refer to the note while
a in particular could refer to the
voltage associated with that node
now I'm going to specify the voltage
drop across a particular component in
terms of the node voltages I'm also
going to assign and 1 to 0 or and 0 to 0
as my ground as a consequence I know
that N 1 is going to be 15 volts my
voltage drop is typically specified in
the same direction as the current that
I've also decided so this convention is
arbitrary but if you want to be
consistent in your work and make it
easier to get partial credit or get help
in office hours etc then assume that the
voltage drop occurs in the same
direction as the current
that's it for our relationships
associated with voltage drop now I'm
going to go over KCl for the relevant
notes and then the last step I'm going
to combine the two into the equation
that you're certainly allowed to use to
express your work on midterms or if you
can skip to the third step immediately
then that's okay just check your signs
here's the second step flowing into n1
is i0 and flowing out is i1 so i0 is
going to be equal to i1 flowing into n2
is i1 and i3 and flowing out of n2 is IQ
flowing into n 0 is n 2 or I 2 and
flowing out of n 0 is i0 and I 3 but
we're almost certainly not going to end
up using that equation because it's the
last of our KCl equations and is
dependent upon the other equations that
we've already written out for KCl I 3 is
equal to 10 amperes so we can go ahead
and make that substitution
I still have to work with i1 and i2
though and I can go after expressions
for them in terms of my node voltages
and components by using the equations
for voltage drop I made earlier
this is the equation that you can jump
straight to if you understand where this
expression comes from as a consequence
of our KCl and also our component
voltages
I'm gonna substitute in and 15 volts for
anyone here and now I have an expression
that only contains n2 and known values
so I can solve for n2 and I'll do that
real quickly
right now so first I'm just going to
copy this over
I'm going to multiply 3 by 6 ohms
I solve for the voltage associated with
n 2 at this point I can solve for I 2
and I won sorry about that
what do I have left I three I know is
10m fears a 0 is equal to I 1 which is
negative 1 amperes
there's a voltage drop associated with
the three ohm resistor which is 15-18
negative three volts and the voltage
drop associated with the 2 ohm resistor
is 18 volts since and zero is ground
this concludes my introduction to node
node voltage component current method or
node analysis without the ability to
collapse voltage sources for KCl